all right
gin and tonic
watch this that's a gin and tonic no i
mean the giant penis straw in my drink
you think that's giant
is that the empty
look can i just have a regular straw
yeah i don't think so we uh we had a
bachelorette party in here last night
and we ordered about 500 of these things
they used four or four of them and uh
we're trying to be green or in this case
a realistic light pink
i'm gonna pay for a drink i don't want
there to be a penis in it
okay
how about i make it up to you how about
a
free hat huh isn't that fun aren't we
having fun at a bar now
what plan are you from
say uranus what planet are you from
we're planet say uranus would you please
just give me a drink okay oh my gosh
it's one of the bachelorettes from last
night she's still here she must be
housed you want to meet her uh no i'm
married
hey sheila
you wanna kiss me on my flat face let's
get the engine primed before the mane
comes huh
oh yeah
this just turned into a salad bar and my
salad needs some tossing it's low carb
and gluten free
gluteus maximum very inappropriate this
is very inappropriate
no what are you doing
did you see her was she here
was the woman here
you met her
yes it was very inappropriate oh hey no
i'm sorry you know i overstepped my
bounds but let me make it up to you can
i can i get your shot on the house
sure
it's a nice luge
open your mouth
oh my god
oh my god call the doctor
sweetheart it's red again